have you ever had a paranormal
experience on anywhere that you've
either traveled or anywhere that you've
shot what about where i lived or where
you lived
i lived in a house that was absolutely
haunted i didn't believe it at first
until a situation
happened then there was no way not to
believe it because the ups guy
saw someone behind me and i'd heard
enough
yeah i don't want to tell you too much
because
i don't want them to
i did have an experience just the other
night
i'm in england i mean how many people
are old that died here
stopping ground for ghosts
courtney was in england with uk-born
long-distance boyfriend johnny mcdade
presenting at the brit awards hi
everyone but she did take some time out
to talk to us about her new supernatural
series shining veil with co-star greg
kinnear you were on friends back in the
day how what's you're reuniting now
what's it like to be back with courtney
you know it's crazy my oldest daughter
was born
like the night before i was going to go
on friends i was so excited to go do it
in front of the live audience and hang
with the the whole gang here and i ended
up having to pre-tape all my stuff with
the swimmer you're crazy
crazy or romantic
and so i blame my daughter
and the first studio stage that we
worked in courtney's like yeah i did
friends here
and the whole thing came rushing back to
me that she has this incredible legacy
another friend of a friend in the cast
lisa kudrow's romy and michelle's high
school reunion co-star mira sorvino the
25th anniversary of romeo michelle's
high school reunion
[Applause]
you know i've always campaigned to do a
sequel and for whatever reason it's
never happened and i don't know that it
will but i wanted to
we are good friends still and talk on
the phone frequently the cool part is
that actually through shining bill i
actually get to work with her friend
courtney lisa and i talked about the
show and courtney was every bit what
lisa said she was going to be and more
that she's just like the consummate
professional
really talented really humble and yet
she's so beautiful like i'm always like
staring at her while we're working i'm
like wow you're so beautiful
and it's almost like she doesn't realize
it but i would like to tell her while we
were shooting like felt you know wow you
look really beautiful today like a kind
of a girl crush are you my muse
i'm rosemary courtney's possessed by
mira's ghost when she and greg move into
an old mansion to save their marriage
but her family just thinks she's
depressed in the stars horror comedy
that premieres march 6th in my dream
she burned me with a cigarette oh
patrick come on courtney are you having
fun playing this character i really am
it's one of my favorite jobs for sure
and i get to go through so many things
that are
you know that women go through besides
maybe the possession i'd love playing it
and i
it's the best role